Good morning, John!
Most of you, 99%, aren't gonna be able to
be at VidCon and, so, you don't wanna hear
about how great it's gonna be.
So, in lieu of being at VidCon or either if
you are gonna be there, I'm gonna give you
an assignment.
VidCon is all about celebrating and appreciating
the culture of online video.
But as, John, you so wisely pointed out last
video, we're pretty old.
The first time I got obsessed with a video
that I downloaded from the internet was 1998.
The year before that was when the very first
viral internet video happened - uh, it was
just this dancing baby.
Except you gotta go "UGACHACA UGAUGAUGACHACA
UGAUGAUGA" (keeps chanting that while singing)
I can't stop this feelin', deep inside of
me."
In fact, I have been into online video for
longer than some of you have been in the world.
Which makes me...kinda depressed.
But it also might actually make me that elusive
thing - an expert.
So, here's what we're gonna do.
You're gonna listen to me talk about how great
the old days were and then you're gonna indulge
me by going to watch a bunch of old online
video that I think is better than anything
being created today, despite mountains of
evidence to the contrary.
It's just like any other course you've ever
taken.
The dancing baby is not in the category of
things that I think are really fantastic and
great.
But a couple years later, in the year 2000,
a project was launched that became the best,
and remains the best, online video project
in history.
Homestar Runner is some kind of bizarre, alien
thing that lives in Free Country, USA, with
his friends: his girlfriend, Marzipan, who's
a baseball bat with hair in a dress; Coach
Z and Pom-Pom and the Cheat and King of Town
and Strong Mad, who is just a square, and
Strong Sad, who is sad and circular and Strong
Bad, who, despite having boxing gloves for
hands, types out responses to e-mails every
week.
There's so much good Homestar Runner content!
You need to grab a friend and take them and
take this wonderful thing that exists into
your life!
It's really good.
HomestarRunner.com.
Check it out.
And note that when we started watching that
show, that little thing took up our entire
computer monitors!
And then weep for us.
There's a kid just fell off a bike outside
of my window.
He's okay.
He's fine.
At the same time as Homestar Runner, there
was all kinds of really interesting Flash
animation stuff happening: The End of the
World, All Your Base Are Belong To Us, Peanut
Butter Jelly Time - these are things that
are important pieces of the culture of the
Internet.
We also got what was probably the first Internet
native genre of video, the animutation.
The animutations were brought into the world
by a lot of different people, but they were
pioneered by a guy who you might know from
his later work, "The Mysterious Ticking Noise,"
Neil Cicierega.
But when bandwidth got good enough, people
could actually start to send and receive video.
THIS kind of video.
And the most important video series of all
time was, of course, "The Show with Ze Frank."
The show revolutionized video.
It took advantage of the fact that the Internet
is a two-way medium.
It allowed people to participate in the project.
It wasn't just about Ze; it was about the
entire sportsracer community.
Pretty much anything you watch on YouTube
nowadays is either directly or indirectly
influenced by Ze Frank.
All this stuff was extremely important in
the Internet's ability to establish itself
as its own, stand-alone legitimate culture,
and since YouTube came along, yes, many more
amazing things have happened.
So much amazing stuff is being made now that
of course, I can't even start to talk about
what's happened since YouTube existed.
This is almost a kind of pre-history of Internet
video that I'm talking about right now, and
I think that it's important for us to understand
that stuff, for us to know where it all came
from.
Also, it's just amazingly fun to enjoy, so
grab a friend, click the links in the description
and just enjoy.
Now I have to go back to VidCon stuff.
I want this video to keep going!
I want to keep making this video!
I don't wanna work on VidCon.
Okay, I'm gonna do it, though.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.